good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can be more
present and mindful rule number four is
my personal favorite and make sure to
stick around all the way to the end for
my thoughts and some special bonus clips
as well also as people are talking if
they say something that really resonates
with you please leave it in quotes and
put it in the comments down below so
other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
when I'm playing football I appreciate
it
I'm nowhere else I'm in the present
there's probably the best part about
best part about my life is that to be in
the present you talk about how do you
enjoy your life how do you find balance
right it's to live in the present you
plead to live like a kid like why do
kids have so much fun because they just
care about what they're doing yeah and
if we thought about what we were doing
all the time you do that when you're on
the football field it's probably the
only place that I can really do that
when I really truly am my authentic self
I mean a lot of people see if my close
close friends do but when I'm on the
football field there's no it's just raw
[Music]
number one start out learning to observe
where you are and what I mean by that is
you know mindfulness while we all think
it's a meditative trick up here and
we'll talk about meditation it's great
but as much as we think of mindfulness
as the mind I like to think about it too
as the full activation of your senses in
the moment what that means is a lot of
people that they'll walk into a
restaurant they'll they'll see their
friend to walk over their friend they'll
sit down they'll eat a meal and
everything but they never actually
looked around the restaurant they never
smelled the smells in the restaurant
they never breathed the air in the
restaurant in serve intentionally and so
they weren't really in the environment
or the situation we've learned to block
out distractions so much so that we can
focus we've also learned to block out
then life so observe where you are bring
your full senses to your next
experiences observation of the setting
the context where am i right now what's
the color of the walls what's the smell
like here What's it feel like here
what's this environment look human
beings we do have a natural ability to
pay attention to our environment I want
you to activate that again consciously
notice where you are and the more you do
that the more you start to feel presence
in life
second observe how you are what I mean
by that is observe how you're
interacting with the environment observe
how are you sitting right now
how are you breathing right now how do
you feel right now observe that more
consistently to see how am I being in
this relationship right now with this
person how am i speaking to them how do
I probably sound to them observing self
in situations starts bringing a more
mindful mentality to us it also allows
us over the long term to be more
intentional
because you know what the more you
observe yourself the more you start
seeing things you don't like about
yourself gosh I don't like how I talk to
her I don't like how I'm missing my
children even being in the room with me
because I'm not paying attention I don't
like how I feel continually I'm always
anxious and negative it all comes and
all are all improvement from there
begins by observing it paying attention
to it my uncle always told me something
early in my life which stuck with me
which is that while you're on the
journey you have to disconnect from the
end goal you know because if you're just
focused on some end goal than you're you
might get there but it'll be hard to
progress past that because you're so
focused on that one destination that
it's like you know you maybe forget
everything in between and maybe you
could have done more in between just be
he always told me like just be here
right now live right now and do the best
you can right now don't worry about what
that end goal is it's great to have
goals it's great to have dreams but it's
just like you get too attached to it and
sometimes it could be a self-destructive
thing so I mean I just kind of try and
progress as much as I can like right now
most people have good great goals I want
to increase my income and lose weight
and get out of debt and be thin and
happy and healthy and have a wonderful
family but then then they decide but
before I start I'm going to take a
vacation to a beautiful place called
someday I'll
and in my estimation 80% of the
population lives on some day aisle
someday I'll lose some weight and
someday I'll read that book and listen
to that program and join the nest
network and there's some day I'll get
out of death some day I'll increase my
income but it's always some day I'll if
you want to be a great success there's
one beta simple rule is vote yourself
off the island for life
if you decide you're going to do
something do it you know they've done
dozens and dozens of studies over the
years they find that there's one major
difference between successful people and
unsuccessful people as successful people
launch they start they get on with it
they just do it unsuccessful people get
the same ideas in the same information
but they've always got an excuse for not
starting you're a guru of time
management and getting things done so
give us the lay of the land and then
we'll do a little deep dive you ready
yes I'm ready for this your head is for
having ideas not for holy
that's it that's it if you get that you
now have the key to keeping creative
space and your brain to be able to have
a lot more room to be a lot more great
if I'm a lot more fun fulfill your life
a lot better
most people are walking around most
99.9999% of BS so walking around with
the constipated psyche with all the
stuff they're trying to manage keep
track of
remind themselves about or whatever
you know that is so some op my mouth is
open because I just I just got it in
that one sentence how profound that is
and I think about what you want to say
basically say it again
so the broke your heads for having ideas
not from holding your head is for having
ideas not for I'm guessing that's
getting men to eat at around that line
the cat food should pop into your head
once if it pops in twice you're not
handling your in your appropriate
engagement with your cat or its food I
mean if I have an idea twice it's just
the reason you do and the reason things
pop into your head for the most part is
simply because you're not yet
appropriately engaged with whatever that
thing is and it's got you as it was that
you got it so interesting you have to
learn the skill and what I just
discovered and developed and really
recognized I didn't make it up this is
nothing new sure this is humanity
Wow that yeah it's what I did was make
explicit what we implicitly do to get
things done
the truth is that
you actually have to use your mind to
get stuff off your mind so a lot of
people now know well I want to have a
clear head go long
or something to clear your head yeah as
opposed to wait a minute why is this on
my mind and what do I need to do to get
it off my mind and that actually
requires thinking those are very
important as you is for everybody
listening to this thinking is required
so that your brain can actually think
think less feel more that is how to live
moment to moment you see the problem is
you think you have time yeah you do have
a lot of time but your time is running
out it's been running out so what are
you gonna do about it to live moment to
moment you gotta ask yourself what am i
doing in this moment
some people say gosh Ralph why do you
make videos on a Sunday on a Monday on a
Tuesday on a Wednesday on a Thursday on
a Friday on a Saturday every day are you
alien
can I get a hello there because I live
moment-to-moment you see the secret of
success is to never rest on your laurels
some people say oh great job Ralph great
video I say which one I'm too busy in
the here-and-now creating and got time
to look back ain't nobody got time for
that we're moving forward with elevating
we're having a great time so once again
to live moment to moment occupy the
present but most of all breathe in that
good ass prana I'm a beautiful day so my
take on this is I think that
entrepreneurs are the most powerful
people in the world not just about money
not just about having strength which it
is - but power in terms of the ability
to influence change the ability to look
at something that we want to change that
we are not happy with in the world and
instead of just complaining about it we
want to go and do something about it
that's what entrepreneurs do
entrepreneurs are gonna solve all of the
major problems of the world because
that's what we do and if you want to tap
into that power if you want to be the
game changer if you want to solve those
big problems then you have to learn how
to be present stop getting distracted
and stop playing small stop checking
your Facebook post because you got one
extra like in the past hour that makes
you feel good stop looking at your email
and pulling out your phone every time a
new notification comes in these
distractions are preventing you from
doing your life's work stop playing
small what am i doing right now I'm
making this video for you what am I
thinking about right now making this
video for you what do I hope to
accomplish I hope that by watching this
video something sparks in here that
helps you play a bigger game that makes
you realize that you're getting
distracted too much and and you're
playing a smaller game you're not doing
the thing you should be doing that's my
sincere hope do I accomplish that maybe
if not I need to work hard or I got to
focus more I gotta get better at what
I'm doing but what I'm not doing I'm not
thinking about what am I gonna eat for
dinner tonight I'm not thinking about
last night's game and how we
lost I'm not thinking about my Instagram
feed and see never got a couple extra
comments in the past 15 minutes because
when I do that then I'm not making a
great video for you if I'm checked out
and thinking of something else that I'm
not in the tasks that I'm doing right
now and that means I would be playing
small me not being present me not trying
to reach my potential is unacceptable
I'd like you to take an audit of your
day and look at how many hours in your
day is actually being spent being
massively productive massively
productive how many hours in your day
it's not that you need to sleep less
it's just in the hours that you're awake
you need to work harder you need to be
more productive and that frustrates me
because you have insane talent because
you have these ideas and you have an
ability and you want to do something
good and you want to have a big impact
and you're sitting on it you're wasting
your time you're checking your Facebook
and doing all these other things that
are getting in the way of you doing
something great stop playing small so
I'd like you to make a commitment I want
you to make a commitment I want you to
say to yourself I'm gonna stop playing
small and start being present I'm going
to stop playing small and start being
present I'm going to stop playing small
and start being present do that for the
next 30 days and the results will
astound you finally you'll be playing at
a level that you're capable of you'll be
doing things that you know you could do
but never actually reached stop playing
small start being present believe
so thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because my Hendron asked
me to so if there's a topic you'd like
me to cover in the next edition of
believe life leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'm also
curious what point did you learn from
this that you're really gonna take home
and apply to your life or to your
business to help you stay more present
leave it in the comments I'm curious to
find out finally I want to give a quick
shout out to Roberto Blake Roberto thank
you so much for one being in my book
your one word is one of the stories that
I told in the book I appreciate you
sharing your awesome story but also for
recently making a video of you with the
book and sharing it with your audience I
really really really appreciate it man
first of all I'm in the book
you're one word by my good friend Evan
Carmichael you guys probably know who
Evan is if you're watching this channel
he has one of the best channels for
entrepreneurship and motivation out
there so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
we'll see you soon
I don't like to think too far ahead so
you haven't thought oh no I don't like
too far ahead people say it like goals
long distance goals and that's too much
for me
I already feel like I'm living it and
then I just carry on the old I you know
carry on day by day already living the
final goal the goal of being the world
champion I already carry myself like I'm
my world champ and I already speak like
I'm a world champion and and that's it I
just carry on day by day so I'll take it
as a corpse a lot again like I said you
were asking ask me about the future I'll
let you I'll let you know a little bit
closer and remain as far all I can see
right now is the cold that's all I can
see if you're an Olympic athlete or
something like you get to the high you
also have to peek at the time it's an
Olympic year you know you could be the
fastest runner in the world and it's an
off year and so you know by the time you
get to the Olympics three years later
you know you aren't anymore so there's a
lot of luck involved in things in the
world I never lived my life thinking
about my next job because I was always
in the last job I could have as far as I
could tell and I think it's a huge
advantage for you to live in the moment
and not to be seething too much I mean
obviously you plan even though your
plans never work out but to if you want
you know the secret is to do a great job
with what you're doing and you know what
you should do is you should perform as
if you were in your next job but not
seed with the ambition to get there and
and project that you'll make people
nervous as hell and you'll kill yourself
I give you an example you know when I
was in high school you know I went to
you know because you heard all those
advisory boards I was it went to Harvard
College at Harvard you know Law School
now when I went to the college from the
high school I came from I know it never
dawned on me that I'd get into that kind
of an Ivy League's it just wasn't just
didn't happen but I applied and I never
thought about it after really I applied
because it just wasn't like it wasn't on
my scope and so when I got a letter that
I got I didn't have any anxiety to it
and when I got that letter I just was
like you know ecstatic and I this and
then my mind opened up but it was just
like a great experience of that was
great when I was in college
and I applied to law school I went down
to the mailbox every day I knew the
consequences of it I was with a bunch of
people who also wanted it and were vying
for it and I was like torturing myself
over and I was imagining what if I do
get it what if I don't get it what are
the consequence of getting it or not and
I tell you I you know it affected my
life in affected you know you know you
know the functionality that's a
difference I tell you if you could
approach every opportunity like I did
the college one you'll be better and
you'll and you'll be happier and if you
live the life tormented about what are
my prospects for the next one when life
is random and you have to be you know
and there's some chance involved in
things you're gonna be tortured I've had
I've had seasons where I've had the
worst surgeries ever you know I've been
through I had seven surgeries you know
and and that alone you know you you ask
yourself time and time again how do you
bounce bounce back from that year and
yeah but I've always used it as you know
taking that time to strengthen myself I
never knew I was gonna play 17 years and
then who could have ever thought that
you don't you don't see when you come
into the league you don't say you know
what I'm gonna play something to you and
you don't even think of it that way you
just say I take a year-by-year and
that's what I try to tell kids don't
move to next year too fast just like
don't go to tomorrow too fast deal with
today deal with right now
you know we've been a lock runner we are
practice and I'm like listen put the
phones down because these moments go go
too fast and when they go on they're
going you know so before you look up
you're in 2 3 5 7 10 12 if you make it
that long well because most of them
don't you know just like you spoke about
early most of these young babies never
see five years never see seven years
never let art in your career you know so
you try to prepare them to understand
what the moment actually feels like and
that's why I think honestly why my
career lasts so long because I always
lived in the moment like it nothing else
mattered to me and I was selfish at
times because even towards my family
nothing else mattered when it came to
that when he came to that I was dialed
there
it's a it's a heck of a blessing to be
here now I'm walking I'm healthy you see
but still making an impact absolutely
right absolutely so you know I I just
tell people I don't know how long
whoever's gonna play but I will say
enjoy every moment
don't don't rush too fast you know let
your years take care of years but go
year by year ago day by day hour by hour
ago minute by minute